foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ah
hello
hello can you hear me
that's a good that's a good way to um
start a live stream hey can y'all hear
me
foreign
we still out here
Aaron despiva was goody fam what goody
I can hear you in my mind stop it
hilarious
okay great because for some reason
I'm not hearing anything
Jaren Drew was popping fam was goody
what's goody Aaron to spiva we got June
in here
hey y'all
some reason I'm not hearing any sound
um
like any of the music or anything
but as long as y'all are
hey Joan Joan in the building
good morning right tinners
I'm out here
yes welcome to the right Ten Club
ah your boy just got out the shower
getting all gussied up for y'all
my moisturizer all greeny we on that
glow up fam we on that glow up
Sean molehill was goody fam
yeah yeah we about to get into it
we about to get into it my G we about to
get into it my G
it's gonna give peeps a minute to jump
in here before we start the live writing
exercise
so exciting
and I don't know uh last week if y'all
remember
I shared
um
the behind the scenes of my new Bert
Kreischer video that's now out on my
YouTube channel I don't know have you
seen it yet have you seen that Bert
crischer video
because it is ouchia in a major way
Shawty
in a major way
it's it's our first video that got over
a thousand views within the first day so
we're on the right track this YouTube
game is another level it's a whole other
skill set to learn but I'm having a lot
of fun doing it
and I have a lot of fun
having y'all
uh support it and be a part of it
um
and and it's infancy if you will
laugh
and uh
Jones said season finale two episode
laugh support drops tomorrow with Joel
Byers oh
[Applause]
how exciting
oh John said good morning comedy fam I
love it
comedy fam ouch yeah Bob Kirk in the
building Bobby Sutton in the building
yeah yeah we we rolling deep now
we rolling deep Steve Rivera
was goody J Bizzle what's goody Steve
good to see you Morris in here oh we
deep
yeah we cooking now fam
and I am so excited
we um
I'm working on another
um
exciting vid video
that I'm super jazzed about
that um
about the world's richest comedian
isn't that fun
so hopefully that'll be out Friday
um
but I can share a little bit with it
because y'all like to because y'all are
here because y'all y'all hang out on
Wednesday so you first started
researching this topic I assume the
answer was easy I immediately went to
the two-time forms highest grossing
comedian when her with his 22 million
dollar tour and 59 million dollar year
I'm talking about Kevin Hart and in a
previous video I break down his comedy
in more detail but his money game is on
another level Kev gets most of his bread
off stage making millions in movies
endorsements and big media deals most
recently Kevin combined two of his
production companies Heartbeat
Productions and laugh out loud into
heartbeat now valued at us so there's a
little there's a little behind the
scenes for you there's a little behind
the scenes for you there
[Music]
just a little something something
um
just to give you a little tease
because I appreciate you all for hanging
out on these live streams every week I
really do
and my wife does as well most
importantly
ah
and no Guinness today my wife was
actually on a call
um
and I did not want to disturb
her stable employment
so yes
Oh Aaron asked if Jay Leno isn't richer
oh yeah that um that was just Kev I go
through a few Comics that build up to
the richest comedian in the world
so um
yeah no worries yeah there are PL there
are a few more there
but it's so exciting I love sharing the
behind the scenes with y'all
but
alas
this is not uh this is not the video
feedback out or video 10 Club this is
the right 10 Club
oh thank you John John said you stepped
up your game on videos nice work Joel
thank you
yeah I'm um
I'm all in on this YouTube shouty
I am here to make it work
what's up Harold
how strange
my
the YouTube comments are not showing up
on
um on my live stream software I'm sorry
y'all just saw the y'all are commenting
Harold's back Harold joined
our
feedback hour last night for the first
time and now he's back for the right 10
Club how exciting Harold thanks buddy
welcome back
homie Dario Jerry Kroll
thank y'all for hanging out over on the
YouTube channel
homidaro said the Chrysler video was
great breakdown of story arc was cool
thank you
Robert Brown was goody what's goody
Jerry said Byron Allen seems to be a
lucrative comedian too for sure actually
had a video idea for like the world's
richest comedian you've never heard of
who is for sure Byron Allen
he's on another level
um for sure
which he actually owns
The Weather Channel I don't know if
y'all knew that
but he bought the Weather Channel and he
he did like Comics Unleashed
uh he's done a lot of cool stuff
but you know who else has done cool
stuff us
and we're about to do cool stuff right
meow
so
without further Ado my friends
yeah I don't know my computer is being a
little bit wonky I can't hear anything
the YouTube comments aren't appearing
but you know what it's most important
is that we're here together today
to write a joke so
the name of the game is
I write we write a joke live together on
the air using today's word of the day
that looks very dark back there
which I guess is fine
yeah I don't know
now I'm a little hot
now the light's a little hot on my face
all right anyway none of this matters at
all I'm like writing a joke live on the
air this is called the light 10 Club
where I just play with my lights until
time is up
anyway it's all a process so don't worry
about it
everything looks great most importantly
you all are here you all look great and
that's what matters the most so
with that being said
let's jump into today's writing exercise
officially
thank you for bearing with my ADD if and
officially welcome
the word of the day is
foreign
[Applause]
the light 10 Club hilarious Aaron
yes indeedy right
I'm definitely running the light today
but without further Ado my friends
welcome to the right tin Club where
we're at a new joke in 10 minutes
today's word of the day
is C
last week's word of the day was Royal
this is what we wrote last week so you
can check that out on our YouTube
channel as well
today's word of the day is c s e a and
we are writing with the uniball 207 Plus
not trying to get too fancy on y'all but
I had a
performed at a holiday party this past
weekend and thought I'd get me a fancy
pen to make me feel good for this
feel-good show so we got us a uniball
207 plus so lovely it's got a nice
smooth grip
it's got a good just overall balance and
it just looks good when you write with a
good pin you just feel good and as Dion
Sanders says
when you look good you play good when
you play good they pay good so
this Eddie Bauer Henley may not look the
best but this uniball 207 is getting
litty so the word of the day is C
and today's date is
the seventh
12-7 slash 22 I will try to stay in
frame
excuse me my friends
maybe if I zoom out a little bit that'll
help
I'll try to write I'll try to I'll try
to stay proper just try to stay proper
put the name of the game here
we're about to for 10 minutes write a
new joke using the word c so feel free
to ride along with me
shout out ideas in the live stream that
we do on this every single Wednesday
and without further Ado my friends
welcome to the right 10 Club
10 minutes on the clock
all right
so 10 minutes the word of the day is C
so the first thing we like to do is just
brainstorm a bunch of different things
that come up when you think of the word
c what are associations what are
connections what just verbal mental
vomit get all the ideas you have out and
we're just brainstorming right now we're
not trying to be funny we're just trying
to get as many ideas out on the page as
possible that then we can then structure
into a joke so first things up see you
know I mean there's no wrong idea here
as well ocean
seaweed okay so seaweed there could be
some sort of play there on like weed
weed and seaweed perhaps
um
ships ships Titanic
seasick
um
Atlantic Ocean
golf Mexico
[Music]
um
Bermuda Triangle
Bermuda Triangle could also be a name of
seaweed perhaps you know but right now
we're still just getting ideas out there
um lost at sea
I know this is kind of angled but this
is how I'm writing it's a it's a weird
it's an awkward angle here
c c Hawks
so perhaps something with that uh
perhaps something with the football team
the Seahawks
um let's see CCC
and you could also do word plays so it
could be
c as in s-e-e could be c as in C in
Espanol
um
c as in someone's name CC
um and also when we think of C what do
we think of waves
Sandbar uh Beach
bottom of the sea
there's also that tuna company what is
it chicken of the sea
um
hmm
c c okay so we got about seven minutes
left as we're brainstorming here usually
like to brainstorm the first half of it
but if something strikes you feel free
to run with it
and as I'm looking at what I have here
sea ocean seaweed ships
Titanic seasick Atlantic Ocean
Gulf of Mexico waves sandbar
surfing
um common phrases I see you like for IC
CC
um I see you
see through you
see sick
so something that's um
standing out here
the seaweed thing still feels like
there's the most potential for maybe a
word play there
lost at sea seasick
so they're coming down to about halfway
through
seaweed it just feels like the obvious
choice but in 10 minutes our goal here
is to not
um over complicate our goal is just to
get a funny idea out there in 10 minutes
which is easier said than done so should
probably get to work on it so let's go
with the seaweed then okay
let's let's play with this let's play
with this premise here because the idea
we're trying to go through here is like
seaweed
and then like
weed weed
so we could do some parallels here
of like what are the differences and
similarities
um green
uh you smoke
Vape
you vape it
you roll it not that I know any of these
things
um green maybe grow in water
how about salt water
um it is edible
okay both are edible huh so there's
something we can maybe play with there
of like edible weed weed and edible
seaweed
I've seen the seaweed snacks before
thank you
what is uh Kush
loud
so now that we've gotten a few ideas out
there we're trying to find like a funny
mistrict we're trying to find a nice
setup punch for this so
think of Wee we would think of seaweed
what would be
an example of like seaweed perhaps it
could be something
from like uh Captain a captain
Captain Crunch
over here we have Snoop Dogg so maybe
someone named like Captain Snoop
um
and when we think of C maybe C levels
Rising
so maybe there's a play with like global
warming there
climate change
ice
melting
DonTrell said seaweed wrap oh yeah
that's interesting
seaweed rap like you're rolling up uh
seaweed that's funny
um
Captain Hyatt C high c
High Noon
all right guys we got about two and a
half minutes yeah
one thing that can help the direction of
a joke is also like finding out like you
gotta you gotta solidify like what is
your premise here what are you trying to
say with this joke so for this joke
what is my premise what am I trying to
say
and that's a great question
um
that seaweed is different from weed weed
Studies have shown that seaweed is
edible
High Tide high Tide
is another um
sea turtles
there's another Association sea turtles
edible you can eat both maybe there's
something there
legal
so maybe it's illegal to
um forage for seaweed
I'm not really sure what the premise is
I think right now I'm just thinking
through
seaweed and weed
um
Snoop okay but the last minute Joel
let's let's get something out of here
okay so
salt water
seaweed edible I think there's something
with edible there
um
edibles
maybe it's um the last edible I ate
made me sick
never eat seaweed
foreign
the last edible I ate gave me mercury
poisoning
mercury poisoning
seaweed
all right all right
in 10 minutes
let's wrap it up here my friends feel
free to comment with the jokes you came
up with
and the name of the joke writing game is
that
you write 20 jokes and you maybe keep
one of them
and some people may watch this and be
like oh you idiot you didn't find comedy
gold in 10 minutes
and that's your prerogative that you can
um project your
comedic genius through a YouTube video
so good for you for feeling that
judgment but I've been doing comedy over
12 years I've interviewed over 400
Comedians and I understand the creative
process of writing a joke and then it's
not always
gonna always so this one
things I could have done better really
get to a premise quicker I really just
thought of seaweed and then was like oh
there's probably some funny thing going
on there but
at the end of the day
didn't really quite land on anything
specific I mean
the closest we got the last edible I ate
gave me mercury poisoning
that's the last time I eat seaweed or it
never eats seaweed
yeah
or the last edible I ate was too salty
that's the last time I have seaweed
something like that you know
so
go forward through the old days my
friends thank you all for hanging out
and watching this I hope you found some
maybe better jokes than I did today but
this is all part of the writing process
so just know that
they're not all gonna all my friends but
the whole goal is that you show up and
you're right every single day and get
yourself closer to finding that next
great joke
yeah we did it
not great
not great but that's fine that's all
part of the process
now I'm gonna post my joke
the last edible I ate was too salty
last set of light is too salty
ah just not proud of this at all it's
kind of embarrassing
but it's part of the process Joel
or maybe the last level 8 was too salty
maybe it was too bland
maybe it wasn't salty enough
so it's too bland so it needed Salt so C
salt
I don't know it's fine
for 10 minutes what are you gonna do
fire me
cool
you know you just always want to get one
especially when it's
your thoughts live streamed onto the air
and when you don't get one you can
become self-conscious
about what we're doing here but it's all
part of the process Joel so you need to
get over yourself and
not worry that you couldn't think of a
brilliant seaweed joke in 10 minutes oh
first world problems
all right
but to the most important part your
jokes my friends I'm excited to jump
into them here
oh homie Dario said never buy drugs from
a pirate all he gave me was seaweed
that's funny
uh he said see what he's used to wrap
Sushi maybe something about rolling a
blunt with seaweed
good call yeah those are some good ideas
there fam
um Miner Fuentes I love this show it's 7
A.M in La well thanks for popping in
love that
oh Bob said Joel no worries you will get
your sea legs back oh I love that thanks
Bob
very funny I love that
that's hilarious
noise let's get to your jokes
let me read some of your jokes live on
the air
as we pull them up here
actually let me go to this screen there
we go
so now we have the word of the day
scrolling across here if y'all have
jokes with the word c feel free to
comment with them
and I'll read them live on the air
so when you post them just be sure to
put joke in front of them the word joke
in front of it
and the homidario's joke
uh
uh my wife desperately wants me to visit
the Bermuda Triangle but at eight and a
half months pregnant I think it's best
we leave all C-sections to the
professionals
[Music]
C-sections that's hilarious
well done
and you know something sometimes when I
write a joke I try to over complicate it
or I try to make it sometimes just a
silly
just a silly goosery you know sometimes
you just want to write a silly goosery
not everything has to
be This brilliant groundbreaking
whatever and sometimes I feel like I
need to
take the pressure off as much when I'm
writing jokes sometimes I I try
too hard to force the funny instead of
just finding a silly angle on it like
C-section that's a funny word play you
know and I need to
it's a good reminder to you know just
have fun with it
so
thank you for that
thank you for that homie Dario very
funny
all right
next joke
we have here
one second I'm we have some spam coming
in our YouTube live stream I am just
getting rid of
all right
next joke I am seeing here
Aaron despiva
uh I used to live by the largest sea I
moved and now live next to a nick
I used to live by the largest sea
see Nick
is it a Scenic wordplay joke
did I miss it
I used to live by the largest I used to
live by the largest sea I moved and now
live next to a nick
did I miss
I think I'm missing the connection there
I didn't know on that one there Aaron
I'm not sure
Aaron says a big D oh
oh so is the word misspelled is that
what
noise
uh June
I might as well ask for a boat this
Christmas the dry winter weather has my
skin so scaly that I already have my sea
legs
very funny
very funny nice
scales in the sea leg that's very funny
nicely done
uh John mulhill there are plenty of fish
in the sea
how did I not think of that phrase
oh my gosh
sometimes you just gotta let go and let
the thoughts let's try to force it's
fine Joel relax let's move on
John mulhill there are plenty of fish in
the sea but I always get hooked on the
ones that are crazy nicely done
Aaron said it was a word play nice sorry
I missed it
sorry
but thank you for posting
a next joke from Bob
from sea to shining C there is no depth
to my love only lots of debt and I'm
drowning in it hilarious
debt
that's hilarious so dead and drowning
see the shining sea sea drowning well
done there Bob
Morris my boss carried on with an affair
abroad wait
my boss carried on with an affair aboard
his yacht
he thought he'd get away with it but his
wife was able to see
right through him oh nice
Joan
I don't swim in the sea the only way I
catch is someone waving goodbye all
right all right all right
very nice
Bobby Sutton I've always considered
crabs to be the spiders of the sea
that's why I call The Sandbar
Charlotte's ebb oh
you silly goose there Bobby
and that reminds me of this video look
at the video Bobby posted look at Joan
oh
so cool
Bobby and Joyce we just went on a hot
breath tour look at Joan oh
and then here's Joyce where's Joyce
there she is
hot breath was on the road this past
weekend doing shows together I love it
oh my gosh
hey
how fun
sorry Joan and Bobby were back to back
so that
remind me of that video Bobby posted in
our Facebook group
stand up or immediate
welcome
we are we are reading jokes live on the
air using the word c if you'd like to
participate
and I see it's Akuma in the building
what's goody fam
what goody
hilarious Jones said the sad funny thing
is I lived in DC Forever and still took
the wrong train home
hilarious
um next joke Jerry Kroll
when I was 15 I was caught selling kelp
they had to let me go no laws against
selling seaweed nice
seaweed joke there very nice Jerry
Winston
uh my human Cannonball friend always
went to went all right let's reset my
human Cannonball friend always went the
extra mile for the cruise ship circus
actually that's how he lost him at sea
nice nice use of C there lost at sea
lost it sees another good phrase man
we missed it
well done there Winston
Sunday
I really enjoyed my cannabis cruise I
love sailing the high seas
nice seaweed high seas that would be a
funny Connection in there too
uh Evelyn
as a kid my mom would take us to the
beach
to stick our finger in the sea anemones
it felt really strange but not as weird
as my dad's pull my finger
[Music]
see just good old-fashioned celery there
I love that hilarious
oh
Gary Bachmann
study finds that rising sea levels could
flood New York City in The Next Century
2020 romantic horse-drawn carriage ride
through Central Park 2120 romantic
gondola ride down Broadway
all right all right yeah yeah yeah
nicely done that Gaddy
Olga they say plenty of fish in the sea
but what they don't say is that my sea
is the Dead one
I love that
very clever there Olga plenty of fish in
the sea but it's the Dead Sea that's
amazing
oh say in the building
says what's good he was goody
what's goody Fame
you got Robert Brown
uh and sorry my you my YouTube comments
are not showing up
in my live stream
uh to bring it on the screen so I
apologize YouTube peeps Robert Brown my
grandpa hates my grandma but he won't
come out and say it when I call my
grandpa
to ask how they are doing he says same
as before just old man in the sea
synchronize
oh
and Peter Parker there are plenty of
fish in the sea but all I catch are
crabs
hilarious
well done
uh next joke
uh uh Mike Marr
I promised my wife we would go on a sea
cruise even though we're drowning in
debt
oh my heavenly day
got me clutching my pearls out here
another good one though C drowning well
done
very well done
oh and it looks like it's Akuma on our
YouTube I remember watching someone
walking along the boardwalk enjoying
their fries
and he got attacked by a gang of pigeons
I couldn't help but think the seagull
the sea Gaul
of these birds
I mean come on the gall seagull see just
fun I just I need to be a little more
silly Gooser I need to just get
loosey-goosey a little bit more you know
thank you all for reminding me of that
as well
for sure
and Bobby says
so far we have a three-way tie between
Jerry Mike and Bobby Sutton
oh snap
a three-way tie between Jerry Mike and
Bobby
somehow my joke didn't win hmm
I don't know about that
fake news
very nice
how exciting
OMG
omg omg
oh Mary made it congrats Mary just right
at the buzzer here
so I'm trying to pull up the the voting
for the tie breaker
or for who's where
and for those of y'all watching
this is
um
all right Ting Club you see the word of
the day is C you see it up there
but uh people are writing jokes using
that word and then
I'm sharing them on the air here and it
looks and we do a live voting for joke
of the day in
our Facebook group
which where is
oh see Harold's joke
search engine advertising isn't what it
used to be yes it made me filthy rich
but on my yacht I always get seasick
nice
search engine app maybe there's
something with CEO or SEO and SCA
perhaps
very clever
oh snap and it looks like Mike Marr just
pulled ahead in a sea of vote to win
joke of the day
with 10 votes
my car congrats buddy
[Applause]
promised my wife would go on a sea
cruise even though we're drowning in
debt
Man Overboard
how fun
how lovely nicely done
congratulations there Mike Ma
OMG
I wish I could hear I can't hear any of
these sounds I don't know why
technical difficulties but I'm glad you
all can hear
have fun
well this is exciting
oh Annabelle said congrats Mike Bobby
says congrats Jones says congrats a
really good one
how lovely
yeah yeah we out you
well I'll tell y'all what I appreciate
y'all so much and a special appreciation
to Bobby and Evelyn Bobby posts the joke
every single day she posts the word
every single day on our Facebook group
and Evelyn makes the meme every single
day so please
please kill them both
some gratitude there for all the extra
work they do for the hot breath first
Beyond even the right pin Club
so we appreciate that so much genuinely
oh thank you so
oh and Jerry said nice joke Mike yes
indeedy
a nice joke indeedy
foreign
Bobby as Bobby said thanks so much Joel
have a super fun blessed and safe week
everybody
yes it is time we go on with our days
Jerry said yes Bobby and Evelyn thanks
for the extra effort for the benefit of
the rest of us Bobby said thanks for the
me Marie's hilarious
yes
we appreciate all your extra effort so
much oh my gosh
thank you thank you
we love y'all so much
but shall we land This Plane my friends
Robert said good round today yeah I
agree yeah this was a good one today
very good I appreciate all for hanging
out man we do this every
Wednesday
at 10 A.M eastern time so come on back
we do a joke feedback hour every Tuesday
at 5 00 PM as well so
kill somebody that knows somebody
we had Harold join us yesterday and
today
after hearing it from a fellow comedian
friend so dude
telling other comedians about this at
your local open mics when you're hanging
out really does make a difference so
please make that
part of your mission this week or not
open mic to tell someone about the hot
breadth of ours
and
let us Land This Plane my friends I love
you all so much
and as we always say here
angels on y'all
y'all have an amazing week
I love you all
we'll see on the other side my friends
bye y'all
I know
that